well i'm joined now by the policing
minister
kit malt house good morning to you and
what did you make of events on
saturday evening when you saw those
scenes on your television screen
well along with everybody else i found
it very distressing and the pictures
were obviously
alarming um which is why the home
secretaries asked for this
uh independent investigation into what
actually
happened so that we can hold the police
accountable which i know they're
happy uh uh to be so um to make sure
that everything
was done in accordance with the rules
look i think we have to reflect on the
fact that
saturday obviously saw unleashing a huge
amount of emotion
and anger not just about the appalling
crime that had occurred
but about a repressed sense of women's
safety
um and that that was in in jeopardy and
under threat
and that's what we'll be talking about
with the prime minister this afternoon
to see what more we can do alongside the
other work that we've been doing
um together me and the home secretary
over the last year or so on this
particular issue
uh christopher dick has said that some
people have been armchair critics and
that police are under
immense pressure do you
back calls that that she should stand
down
no i don't and i do recognize that the
police are in an incredibly difficult
position i mean throughout this pandemic
we've asked them to do a job that
they've never done before and to
uh stand between uh the public if you
like and this terrible
virus in a way that none of us are used
to and certainly they aren't as well
um and so that very very difficult
position that they're in
uh needs to be reflected in our
contemplation of of this you know in the
vast majority of cases
uh the police and the public have
managed this situation extremely well
between them this particular
circumstance where emotion was running
naturally extremely high everybody
incredibly
uh distressed about what had happened
and indeed the police themselves
devastated
uh i know about the implications of this
case that in these circumstances it's
very important
that we get to the detail of what's
happened and that's i think what will
emerge over the next couple of weeks
you say that the police are in a
difficult position they would echo that
because they're saying that simply
they've been there repeatedly called on
by the the home secretary to be tougher
in their enforcement of covid
restriction laws
so they're only being they've only done
as they've been asked to do
well we've all been very focused on uh
suppressing the virus
um and it's now more important than ever
uh that we do so
you only have to look in the newspapers
across europe to see that the virus is
re-emerging in countries
uh in the eu um and some i think italy
contemplating
another national lock down shortly so
we're at a very
powerless moment it's only a few weeks
since the nhs was under
uh significant stress and so we are very
focused
the home secretary has sorry just to
interrupt but do you agree that the home
secretary has
called on uh the police to be stricter
in their enforcement of covert
restrictions
she certainly called on the police and
the public to observe the law
and make sure that maths gatherings are
avoided and pointed out that they are
illegal we're obviously not privy to the
detailed operational decisions that are
taken quite rightly so
and that's i think what the
investigation of the next couple of
weeks
will have a look at to make sure that
the decisions were made in accordance
with that kind of protocol and with the
law but look we're all struggling with
what is a very very difficult situation
we totally understand and i feel it
myself the anger
that has arisen because of this terrible
terrible crime and what we now need to
do is make sure we're all focused
on the notion of making our streets as
safe as possible for everybody
but particularly for women and girls
were you aware
as an individual of how widespread
women's experiences of sexual
harassment has been uh i was and i have
to say
um uh 10 years ago or so when i was at
city hall as deputy mayor for policing
to the then mayor boris johnson we
published the first ever
violence against women and girls
strategy in a major global city
focusing on specifically many of the
issues
that people are still sadly raising that
are
you know it seems endemic in parts of
our society and that's why for example
uh we brought forward the domestic abuse
bill which is reaching the end of its
passage
uh through the house at the moment uh
which will significantly enhance our
ability to deal
with domestic violence and abuse and why
we're very focused for example
on the problems we're seeing in rape
convictions and have an end-to-end rape
review
which is currently on the blocks should
be published shortly hopefully
that will renew our efforts to try and
achieve justice for those women
who are victimized in that particular
horrendous crime type so there's been a
huge amount going on for some time
i do understand people's frustration
though that we're not making
as fast progress as perhaps they would
have liked but they should be assured
that there is enormous effort going into
this and that's what we'll be outlining
with the prime minister this afternoon
will sexual harassment be looked at as a
specific crime
well this is obviously one of the issues
that we we're asking for views on
at the moment one of the responses to
this terrible crime to sever
everett's terrible killing was for us to
reopen
our call for views um about violence
against women and girls
and we've had something like just in the
last couple of days something like 64
000
uh people have come online at got dot uk
to give us their views about
where they think policy should go into
the future we'll be digesting that over
the weeks to come
and be bringing forward a new violence
against women and girls strategy a
refreshed one
later in the year to to really confront
some of these issues
uh labour's saying that the excuse me
the police crime and sentencing and
courts bill that's to be debated this
week
they're saying that that could lead to
harsher penalties for
damaging a statue than than attacking a
woman they've been quite critical
yeah i'm i have to confess to being
disappointed and a bit confused by the
labour approach because obviously the
bill contains
huge uh um protections for the public
not least
with regard to serious sexual offenders
for example
who will spend a lot longer in jail look
on the monuments thing
criminal damage already carries a
penalty of up to 10 years
in prison but it's limited uh to shorter
centers is that the value
of the item is less than five thousand
pounds now that obviously
um ignores the emotional
value or the symbolic value particularly
of of war memorials and other memorials
and so we're just removing uh that
anomaly um
and it seems unusual to me that they
would pick that particular
issue to focus on when there's so much
more in the bill not least for example a
serious violence duty which is being put
on
local authorities and health services in
an area
to work with the police in identifying
the drivers of violence in their
location
and then coming up with a strategy to
deal with it right we we're using this
bill to put everybody shoulder to
shoulder
on violence across the board not just
violence against women and girls
important though that is
but violence in society and for labor to
be voting against this bill just seems
to me confused
what about in terms of um rights to to
protest some criticism there as well
that this will
disproportionately affect uh people's
right to actually protest on the streets
well again i'm i'm concerned that
they're using this particular moment of
of natural anger in our country and
upset
to inflame what is actually quite mild
uh changes
to public order legislation you know
public order legislation
has been in place since 1986 it hasn't
been updated
we're removing some anomalies and
loopholes in the law we're
implementing a law commission
recommendation around public nuisance
and just aligning conditions on protests
that apply at the moment to marches and
processions
onto static uh um protests
so the two are are seen in the same uh
breath
and also taking steps to protect the
operation of our
democracy so that people who try and
prevent members of parliament accessing
the house for the purposes of voting or
indeed prevent people attending at court
will be stopped from doing so you know
we've seen protests over the last
few years adapt its tactics and we
obviously have to adapt
the legislation in what i think is a
relatively mild way
recognizing that protest and freedom of
speech is absolutely
fundamental to our democracy but it has
to be balanced against the rights of
others
to go about their business and indeed
against the operation of our democracy
which is even more vital
in terms of crimes against women can you
see
misogyny the act of misogyny actually
becoming a crime
because it isn't at the moment is it
well was to say street
harassment um and some of the i mean
it's been really distressing
to see some of the episodes that have
been um shared
through social media and in the
newspapers over the last
uh few days and as i say having having
worked on this in the past
um it didn't come as a surprise to me i
have to say
but it did come as a source of anger
along with everybody else
and i think we're all uh have a duty in
politics
to focus on those issues and see what
more we can do as i say the
call for people's views is open now i
would urge people to go on and share
their anger distress
their personal experience of these
situations so that we can shape policy
into the future
and get it right for everybody i want to
just ask you a final question about um
astrazeneca and the fact that seven
countries have now suspended
its use um pending at the inquiries
about possible
blood clots as a result of using it um
do you believe that we should now be
looking at the use of of astrazeneca's
because many people have already had
this vaccine
no i don't and the scientists tell us
that
all is well and that the incidence of
these
particular problems is is no greater
than you would expect in the population
at large and that these things naturally
occur anyway
obviously the vaccine's been through
very very stringent testing before it
was
authorized for use we have some of the
highest standards in the world
for medical uh products and for testing
as a former
uh or well in fact founder of the all
party group on life sciences before i
became a minister
i can attest to that um i'm hoping to be
called for a vaccine in the next couple
of weeks myself and if it's astrazeneca
i will happily take it in my arm